today on things I think I know how to do
I'm gonna show you how to Moss your roof
this is at least how I Moss my roof and
if you want a must your roof you can
Moss it like this too first thing that
you need is a lot of moss it's no
coincidence that we chose this location
for cabin land because it's mossy so you
can actually order it online it comes in
sheets and you got to kind of liven it
up and spray it with water maybe even a
little food coloring or something like
that cuz it's not as thick and lustrous
as this but if you live in a place that
has a lot of moss you might be in luck
and this is how you can wash your roof
so I made up this little mock roof right
here because my roof is different than
your roof the angles the pitches but
this sort of concept can work on any
kind of roof and here's your basic roof
right here you got your rafters you've
got your sheathing your plywood your
vapor barrier right here and then you've
got your metal roofing that's we put on
top this is corrugated it's nice it
lasts a real long time the thing that
doesn't last forever actually are these
gasket screws these little gaskets they
tend to wear out but this metal is going
to last a long long time
okay so here's our mock roof we also
have a lot of moss Mike drill
I like this drill it's little I have the
bit that fits these screws these screws
are self tapping they have like a little
drill bit on the tip basically that
bores through the aluminum or galvanized
steel I don't even know what this is
it's metal though wait hold on yeah it's
definitely metal this tip bores through
it and it self drills it tap it and then
squishes this gasket down and makes a
seal I don't think I have any other
materials oh wait I forgot most one of
the most important materials I forgot
chicken wire
right here this is your standard cluck
cluck chicken wire what you ever to this
point you want to attach the chicken
wire to the roof we're going to just
continue to use more of these same
gasket screws I want this little bit of
chicken wire to dangle over a little bit
because the when I want that when I want
this moss to go on what I want is for I
want it to kind of drape over so it kind
of looks like it's growing off of the
roof so I'm gonna just send it a little
long like this and let it kind of go
over and that's gonna give me a nice
little thing to weave the moss into
later then I'm gonna take one of my
screws so I'm gonna put it right here in
the vertex the cook oh my gosh do you
know what I just noticed
I've done a Texaco you don't want to get
up in the vertex of the hexagon you're
gonna get right up in this little vertex
I love that it's a hexagon put it right
there and the little vertex so when this
this gasket school uses around the
chicken wire that's good that's a nice
seal now we've got our chicken wire
fastened to our roof okay like this it's
fastened no if you notice I'm leaving
I'm not putting too many screws in it if
you put it down wicked tight it's gonna
be really hard to read that moss in
there so you want there to be like
little spaces so like you can get work
your fingers in there and I've got
clumsy fingers so I want decent sized
holes or gaps or spaces I want there to
be some play in here like this if you
look down like here it kind of looks
like rolling hills that's the way you
want it to look now we're ready to Moss
it okay we're ready to go we've got
different kind of mosses that we've
collected when you collect moss don't
take from the same spot don't take all
the moss don't scrape the moss all off
of one tree take a little bit from here
a little bit from here and please do so
gently we went around and we collected
different kinds of mosses these are some
of my very favorite we want to weave
through here all this moss and we're
just gonna fill this up but we're gonna
fill up with different kinds of moss and
kind of make it look I don't know like
it's natural like it grew here this is
what's so amazing about mom you know how
you see moss grow on metal you can see
Moss grow on on an old car or something
like that it's because Moss doesn't
actually need to grow in soil that being
said what we're doing is we just need to
get the the moss woven in enough for it
to stay there so when it's at a pitch
the roof is like pitched up like a
normal roof it won't fall down so I'm
gonna gently start weaving in little
bits poking it through bringing it out
so it stays in there it doesn't need
much if I lift this up and show you it
stays there it's happening it could be
at like a ninety pitch roof vertical you
could be at like a 12 12 a 45 pitch roof
you could be at most roots which are
like that steepness it stays it doesn't
need much and you see I only pushed it
through in a couple of places over the
years this is going to grow and it's
going to
weave into itself and it's gonna
actually kind of take over it's gonna
bind itself around this chicken wire now
the reason we got really big sheets of
it you'll see that when you spread it
out it's it's kind of a pain in the butt
to put a little bit in at once if I had
all pieces like this I'd be putting in a
gush like one little piece of chicken
wire at a time impatient I can spread it
out like this and cover a large area ooh
try to keep that fern in there so I've
got it laid out right here like this now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start just going through and weaving
little bits at a time
we're just stitching this together we're
going through I know that I put this big
ol chunk every place needs a little bit
of stitching here and then I'm gonna go
in the middle I'm gonna poke my finger
through and kind of grab some of that
and wrapping it around there so that's
hooked up and my roof if you notice the
metal is proud it's longer than where
this ends on right here where the fascia
board would be okay if this is say this
is your Eve or this is your gable end
you put some fascia board here
the roof would extend past it and then
you'd have this Moss which dangles past
that people ask me a lot of times does
this Moss destroy the roof does it kill
the roof well not only does this metal
roofing withstand a lot of terrible
conditions wet rains Sun heat cold all
that stuff so it can live a long time
even under those adverse conditions the
mosque actually protects it the moss
absorbs water so when rain does fall on
it before it even has a chance to hit
the roof this Moss is going to start
absorbing that water in keeping it off
of the roof altogether another cool
thing is that the mosque also keeps the
sunlight off of it so it kind of
stabilizes that and keeps that yury off
of it my mom used to rub zinc on my nose
and put 50 proof on me and this is
better I wish I'd put Moss on me so this
is like a fifty proof sunscreen this is
like a five hundred proof sunscreen
right here okay the other thing is look
it's like this hole it's basically not
even touching the roof this is held on
it's kind of resting there it's like a
blanket it's not just like leeching down
onto it and stuck onto the roof and and
kind of eroding it and corroding it and
digesting it and destroying it it's just
resting on it there we have it we put
all our moss in is it gonna stay you ask
when it's up at full pitch when it's all
steep and pointy and not just flat check
it out what about when the wind comes
what about the rain that's how we Moss a
roof stay tuned for the next episode of
things I think I know how to do where
I'll try to mansplain something else to
you Mike
[Music]
[Applause]
please be sure to LIKE and subscribe
this channel so you never miss an update
and please back us on patreon so we can
keep these free videos coming yes free
ain't free we need you back us please